yeah I mean it's it's it's a it's
admirable I truly I truly love it and
those books those two books on each side
of your head american-made Bush and CIA
conspiracies from the boys and the
trucks of Jeffrey Epstein now right
today is this morning who was arrested
by the FBI oh my goodness we never
thought it would happen just never
Prince Andrew's partner in crime ghilane
Maxwell also the madam you call her
madam - Jeffrey Epstein
no not just the chief procurer and
co-conspirator but also someone who
participated in assaulting the kids now
what does this mean for her to be
arrested by the FBI today it's huge
because if it's not getting swept under
the carpet and it's a conspiracy case
like this I looked at the indictment
today I didn't want our video whereby I
read the indictment out on YouTube on a
live stream and she has got six charges
the last two a perjury which aren't that
significant but the first four are
hugely significant trafficking kids for
sexual abuse and participating in the
abuse she's facing multiple life
sentences so the only way she's going to
get out of this situation now is if she
turned snitch and puffs up some big
names so how long before she gets
suicided that's it she's in she presents
the exact same risk now to the elites
who she's an Epstein
that Epstein presented but if she gets
whacked dad is just too obvious well if
she goes and names Bill Clinton I'm
Prince Andrew in a court trial
government agencies have to take action
if she says they are having sex with
kids
I can't get to that it's gonna be
stopped Jesus Christ this [ __ ] gives me
chills man it is so [ __ ] scary it's
great because the Epstein case all of a
sudden there was no news for days and
then BAM they grab her the chief procure
know she's close with the CIA right she
knows people in the CIA right
she's got connections so do you think
show my new this was coming if you go
back to the history of Robert Maxwell he
had connections of all the intelligence
agencies he was far bigger player than
Abstergo Lane but once you become a
liability they take you out right he was
off the canary islands on his yacht the
lady ghilane thinking that he was some
money was forthcoming from a certain
country and an intelligence agency and
they had a hit squad in dinghies below
the radar he's up on deck they come up
they were planning it BAM get him in the
neck of a syringe with a poison that's
untraceable that's how they took him out
and it's still debated to this day how
he died or in the assassination of
Robert Maxwell and I have interviewed
Ari been Menashe who's prominent in that
it looks like that's what went down so
when these people even though they've
got all these connections the world and
Maxwell he could sit down with the
President of Russia President of Israel
president of America with mi5 the CIA
mi6 the Mossad you name it right and
these people become a liability they
take they've got a girl so she can have
all the connections in the world but
once you become that liability you've
got to go I know you watched the Epstein
documentary on Netflix filthy-rich yeah
what was your what were your thoughts on
that
overall well I wasn't see is watching
the victims yeah
did you know you interviewed a lot of
those women about the interactions with
others online and just to hear the judge
say that you know they were human beings
and they were victims they weren't child
prostitutes and criminalized which is
what don't you it's and his crew tried
to do to them
and a Koster absolutely disgusting
people just to see that the happiness in
them to be acknowledged as human beings
and today this must be a huge day for
though I've been watching all day on
Twitter to see if Maria or Virginia have
tweeted yet because they must be
inundated right now this is a result of
their bravery what has happened that
they've not dropped this case and
they've kept going no matter wha you
know Maria fama had private detectives
outside of her house shining lights and
in the middle of the night friend in her
life one of the bodyguards that works
the property was you know psyching
himself up to killer and she might get
out of that situation the things that
these women went through its proper
horror movie stuff so you know I urge
people all over the world to go on
Twitter and support Virginia and Maria
Farland and send them a tweet and follow
them I wanted to touch a little bit on
your book about Pablo Escobar and George
Bush George senior right yeah of course
yeah so who was Barry seal okay so my
book American made is about the CIA
cocaine flying pilot Barry seal there
was also a movie starring Tom Cruise
which was a complete whitewash it did
show some things as they allow more to
be shown but a whitewash about the more
hardcore stuff so the subtitle is who
killed Barry seal and the George HW Bush
are Pablo Escobar okay so who killed him
visit us at pablo or was it George Bush
all right so you've got Barry seal
flying in cocaine to Arkansas you've got
this operation is run by George HW Bush
and Oliver North with full national
security CIA protection the state of
Arkansas is run by then Governor Bill
Clinton so he's providing the police
state police to protect it and it all
went wrong when two kids were found dead
on railroad tracks and the first chapter
this is the stories of four people into
we
throughout this book okay and Linda Ives
is the mum of Kevin Ives he was one of
the boys on the tracks
okay now evil Bill Clinton had a corrupt
medical examiner who basically would
give him whatever verdict
method of death he required so the
method of death on these two boys it was
ruled that they'd got so high on weed
had gone into a psychedelic trance and
laid down side by side on the railroad
tracks and the train had run over them
well actually they'd seen the drug drop
and the bodyguards had seen the kids and
the kids were snuffed out that's what
really happens and Linda Ives has been
trying to get justice from Bill Clinton
to this day and he's Nicky won't even
acknowledge er and how do you how do you
know this like how can you confidently
say this because Charlene Wilson was
there at the scene and Dan Lassiter she
was a drug-addicted lady who was being
used by these players dan Lassiter was a
guy who was pretending to be dr.
Lassiter picking up medical organs Terry
Reid but a wrote a book called
compromised he was working with Barry
seal he was he didn't know about the
coke until later when he got moved to
Mexico after Barry field died but Terry
Reid and other pilots have all come out
and said that they were bringing the
coke in and terry lee Reid he's got a
book called compromise it's huge and
this is a CIA guy I need details
it details the whole thing so it's not
from conspiracy theorist all my
information is from people who arrested
people who were cops protecting the
Clintons and people who were working for
the CIA and all these people's stories
correlate with each other absolutely
because it's the truth
I believe it a hundred percent and even
the public you know ten twenty
have you told the public that the US
federal government was waging a war on
drugs while bringing the cocaine in that
spawned the crack epidemic you were
called the conspiracy theorist Oh 100%
well now everybody accepts that war in
Nicaragua had to be financed and was
being financed by cocaine and George HW
Bush no love enough of running that
people are fully accept but now
okay so Barry seal was flying in cocaine
yeah to where Arkansas and weapons back
down to Nicaragua while all this while
Bill Clinton was the governor of
Arkansas yeah I'm Bill Clinton was
hooked on cocaine himself his brother
Roger was hooked on coke and got
arrested in a cocaine deal and the
undercover cop recorded him saying some
of this is for Bill he's got a nose like
a vacuum cleaner there's a there's a
video recording of Roger Clinton after
he's been arrested saying a bunch of
crazy expletives and yeah that's what
those guys were like they get on TV and
say they fighting the war on drugs and
behind the scenes they are running the
drugs and then locking up all the lowest
level users to make profits off it this
is how psychopathic and evil these
people are Clinton ended up hospitalized
because of nasal damage from all the
coke he was doing Hillary went down the
hospital threatened all the staff
deviated septum right you know and said
to all the staff any of this comes out
you are ruined your careers are over I
will wipe the floor with you all the
women that Clinton was having sex with
some consensual some not lawsuits were
selled hillary found out where all those
women were and they were stalked pets
were murdered and they were threatened
never ever to say a single thing no
because she was jealous
she was just supporting his rise to
power because their rise to power was
together
[Laughter]